hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Game of Thrones Q&A so there
are three more episodes left we know the
titles for the next two episodes we do
not know the finale title yet I know a
lot of you are asking questions about
Cersei what's going on with her I think
she's gonna be pretty close to what
happens to her in the books so I tried
to avoid potentially super spoilery
questions even though they have changed
a whole bunch of stuff from the books
you know I still think that they're
sticking close to a couple really clear
storylines most notably what's going on
to King's Landing I think there'll be
some really fun episode 8 9 10 moments
that mere moments that happened last
season so don't be surprised if you feel
a little deja vu with certain moments
that happen in King's Landing on a
question so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet
first question Ana asks do you think
that Stannis will sacrifice his own
daughter and if he does what kind of
power will we see actually you know I
think you know if his daughter gets
sacrificed it'll be someone else like
it'll be his wife that sacrifices
Shireen I do think that Stannis will
push on to Winterfell and he'll be
successful like he'll make it there but
I don't think that he's gonna sacrifice
Shireen because she's his only heir
right now if he gives her up he won't
have anyone to succeed him he'd have to
try to adopt Jon or someone else as his
next heir he's trying to be king so I
don't think he's gonna do anything as
foolish as that but his wife Solis has
clearly drunk Milla Sandra's kool-aid
remember they had that really weird
scene with Melisandre in the bathtub
last season where she told sceles you
must bring Shireen Melisandre is the one
that's pushing for the sacrifice so she
could either try to convince solis to
sacrifice Shireen without Stannis
knowing about it or she could just
sacrifice Elise I think you know given
the option Stannis would rather lose his
wife than lose his daughter so it could
be Stannis too like he could be forced
to make the choice if you don't
sacrifice one of these two women the
same thing that happened at Blackwater
will happen again we need the blessing
of the red God so if they do decide to
go down that route I think Solis would
be the one put to flame as for what kind
of magical blessing they might incur
from the red God I think it would just
be support magic like it would weaken
the enemy troops or you know weaken the
battlements it wouldn't be like a giant
sinkhole opening and swallowing all the
Bolton troops up or anything like that
next question Jason asks
what object do you think Sansa picked up
when she was walking with Ramsay it
looked like a dagger but it was hard to
see do you think that Sansa would try to
kill Ramsay oh I you know I'm hoping so
much I mean it looked kind of like a
barrel opener or something with the hook
on it or a bottle opener something
really sharp that she would just gauge
someone's eye out with I don't think she
would have picked it up if she wasn't
gonna use it so she's gonna stab someone
maybe more than one person could be
Miranda could be Ramsay could be Theon
the idea is is that Sansa is going
through similar things that she went to
with Joffrey in season one you know
remember when he made her look at her
father's head on the pike like Ramsay
made her look at that woman who have
been flayed and hung up you know very
similar moment to that season one moment
so now maybe Sansa is gonna say enough
is enough and she's finally gonna do
something about it
next question Taylor asks how do you
think Tyrion will get Danny to trust him
she's been taught that the Lannisters
are the worst enemies of the Targaryen
's well you know I think the best thing
that Tyrion could do is just tell her
the truth I've been kicked out of King's
Landing I had to flee for my life I was
gonna be executed my sister wants to
kill me that you know that kind of stuff
he played the enemy of my enemy is my
friend card he's very smart so hopefully
he'll help her with some problem that
she has some small problem and she'll
start to trust him a little bit she's
not gonna completely trust him right
away you know that'll be like season six
territory she'll trust him as much as
Littlefinger and the Queen of thorns
trust each other next question Marty
asks what do you think they have in
store for Loras well Loras is actually
one of those characters who's like way
off of his book plot in the books like
where we are right now he's way off in
another part of the world something the
high Sparrow said I think is really
important they may find the mothers
mercy you know say they were to confess
their sins they might be shown mercy so
just because they're going on trial
doesn't mean they're gonna get executed
or sentenced to death like Tyrion was
last year and remember he said that the
church is conducting the trial it's not
going to be a jury of their peers
the idea being that Cersei or the
Tyrells can't buy the jurors next
question Chris asks did they arrest
Cersei because she slept with Lancel or
because they also know that she's been
with Jaime
well mostly she was arrested because of
the Lancel stuff when Littlefinger said
that he had a gift for the Queen of
thorns you know a beautiful young man
she was talking about Lance all the
information that Lancel had that he had
slept with Cersei the Queen of thorns
would be able to use that as leverage to
help Marjorie and Loras like look here
you have my grandson and my
granddaughter but look the Queen here
much more important person has done way
worse stuff everyone will still go on
trial but the idea is is that they have
the bigger fish now Cersei being the
bigger fish as of right now the high
Sparrow does not know that Tommen is
Jamie's son they don't know about that
yet
they just know about the Lancel stuff
next question John asks hey Charlie just
wondering what do you think about the
bran tying scene I felt alarm bells
ringing when she gave him the antidote
what if it's another poison well you
know I don't think it was a poison it
she seemed pretty genuine when she said
I think that you're beautiful too one of
the purposes of that scene I think is
just to imply that they're not gonna be
at each other's throats for the rest of
the season so they'll probably find some
sort of balance but you know whatever
Prince Durant ends up deciding to do
with all of them his big thing is is he
doesn't want to start a war with King's
Landing so he's not gonna try and
execute Jamie that would definitely
start a war it seems like bran and the
sand snakes have a certain mutual
respect now I mean they they probably
don't like each other not all the sand
snakes like bran but I don't think
they're outright enemies anymore if they
ever were to begin with they really just
kind of accidentally ran into each other
because the sand snakes were on a
mission Jaime and Bronn went on a
different mission and they they all just
kind of collided hopefully it'll also
turn into like a Tyrion Daenerys
situation to where you know the enemy of
my enemy is my friend where they they
find a way to work together
next question Maximiliano asks do you
think that it might be possible that the
series is doing the opposite of the
books like Sansa going to the wall to
meet Jon Snow no no I don't think that
Sansa is gonna go to the wall to meet
Jon or anything like that I know a lot
of you are asking about pink letter
stuff like that if they do pink letter
it probably at the very end of the
season then they use it as a cliffhanger
I do think Stannis will make it to
Winterfell with his army and I do think
that Sansa will make it out of
Winterfell maybe with reek maybe by
herself but I don't think we'll get any
further than that this season next
question taylor asks why do you think we
saw Brienne looking at the tower in
Winterfell
bran has to do something before the end
of the season what do you think she's
gonna do well you know I think around
the time Stannis starts to arrive with
his army and Sansa that gets ready to
you know stab someone with that you know
whatever it is the bottle opener
I think the Brienne will make her move
on Winterfell too and like they'll all
kind of converge on each other every
time Brienne
tried to help one of the stark children
it's ended really badly for her so I'm
hoping that things go a little bit
better this time but I wouldn't be
surprised if something really bad
happens to Bri and when everyone
converges on each other at Winterfell
next question making plays asks since
there's a way to communicate with White
Walkers do you think that someone would
try to make peace with them or you know
speak to them in some way so you talk
here yeah you're talking about will Jon
Snow or someone try to talk to the White
Walkers I think we'll see the White
Walkers communicate openly with other
people at some point maybe this season
you know hopefully this season the White
Walkers themselves have their own
language towards our Martin describes it
is like the sound of ice cracking so
even if they do speak to people on the
show you wouldn't be able to understand
what they were saying they'd have to
communicate with body language just by
like pointing at stuff most of the time
that when we've seen them on the show
they're just doing things they're not
trying to communicate with anyone
hopefully they will not try and subtitle
the White Walkers that would be a big
disappointment I think it'd be more
effective if the White Walkers spoke in
it you know it sounded like ice cracking
and we were just left to guess what they
said I think that'd be much more
effective next question Oxana asks what
did Cersei mean when she said to Tommen
who do you think the first victim will
be well she was talking about starting a
war with the faith for arresting
Margaery just saying that Margaery would
be a casualty if a battle were to start
whether the faith killed her or peasants
killed her or something else the object
of the thing that you're trying to save
would be the first casualty I think it's
a nice mirror for what happened during
Robert's rebellion who were some of the
first casualties of that Ned's older
brother and his father when they found
out that Lyanna stark had been taken
they went to King's Landing to petition
the Mad King but the Mad King ended up
executing them based on what Cersei said
you could extrapolate that you know had
Ned's father and his brother and in a
couple of other Lords not marched on
King's Landing with force that maybe if
they'd tried a more diplomatic approach
they might not have died Lyanna stark
might not have died and Elliott of Dorne
might not have been killed by the
mountain during the siege of King's
Landing that's why I love Littlefinger's
comment you know a couple episodes ago
how many tens of thousands had to die
because Rhaegar chose your aunt thank
you so much for so many questions though
these are always a ton of fun to do so I
mean there's there's a lot of
speculation to how close the show is
gonna stay to the books so as we you
know get through the next couple of
episodes I'll try to point out some
changes from the books if that's the
case there's still a couple really
spoilery things that I think are gonna
happen so I'm just gonna wait till they
either happen or don't happen on the
show but congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Peter Chipola you win an
HBO now subscription just be sure to DM
me on the back end of my channel so I
get your contact info next week's
giveaway will also be another HBO now
subscription if you guys have any
special requests for bonus videos next
week just let me know in the comments
there isn't going to be any kind of
break in the episodes we're gonna get
episode eight next week so be sure to
subscribe to get that just in case you
guys haven't seen it I did a bonus video
all about the history of maester aemon
you can click here to watch that and you
can click here for my episode 7 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you